حق
حمده والصلاه والسلام على من لا نبي من
بعده واعلموا عباد الله ان الله تعالى
امرنا بامر بدا فيه بنفسه وثنى
بملائكه قدسه وثلث بالمؤمنين من عالم جنه
وانسه وقال تعالى قولا كريما تعظيما لقدر
نبينا وتفهما لنا وتعليما
وتفخيما له صلى الله عليه وسلم
وتعظيما ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صل وسلم وبارك واكرم وانعم
وتحنن وتعطف على سيدنا محمد طب القلوب
ودوائها وعافيه الابدان وشفائها ونور
الابصار وضيائها وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم
تسليما كثيرا كثيرا اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال سيدنا محمد كما صليت على
سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال سيدنا ابراهيم انك
حميد مجيد وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد كما باركت على سيدنا ابراهيم
وعلى ال سيدنا ابراهيم في العالمين انك
حميد مجيد مكمل علوم الاولين والاخرين
مولانا ومولى الثقلين ابي القاسم ابي
الزهراء محمد فيا ايها الراجون شفاعته
اكثروا من الصلاه والتسليم عليه فان
صلاتكم نور على الصراط حين تمرون
عليه ديذ ان
سستر ماي
خطبه
حنا
ران
مم
grand جي ع عليه
السلامي ع عليه السلام ‏without a father
is a miracle from the power of الله سانه
wal and i will show you that the history
of the prophets and messengers before
isa عليه السلام was full of examples of
الله power to
create life from nothing
سوره ال
عمران سوره نر
قران الله سبحانه
وتعالى ال
عمران الله سبحانه وتعالى قران سوره ال
عمران
ابرام
ران
all
الله
alling
allowing
[Silence]
‏my you are
all
[Silence]
‏not
شيطان
الله
her her gr in the best way and made
زكريا
‏said from where
this it الله
الله
he
[Silence]
زكريا
الله سبحانه
وتعالى نوح عليه
السلام
اسلام نوح عليه
the the to be the
people ادم عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
تعال
ابرا
عمران البخاري رحمه
الله ابن عباس رضي الله تعالى
عنهما ابرام
رانس محمد صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وعليهم
اجمعين الله سبحانه
وتعالى
all
his الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله
guard
ابرام
اسلام اسماعيل
ايزك جايكوب
يعقوب
اسباط محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ابراهيم
عمران عس عليه
السلام ال
عمران
ران
مم
سليمان
ران
ماتان
ح are best
man
جزاكم الله
خيرا
s
حران
[Silence]
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏are
allowing
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
شيطان
[Silence]
دعا
جزا الله
خيرا brs we have we have that the
corner i
want many brs that
place space fors جز
الله ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله سبحانه
وتعالى and
sisters mov
her this moved her to make the pr to
her that he bl
her would this child to ‏his serv and
the
serv the
chch but
when
said not
like
that
not church
chch
ابو هريره رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم مم عيسى عليه
السلام ابو
هريره
[Silence]
شيطان
ساره اسحاق عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ساره
حكيا الله سبحانه
وتعالى
عليه
السلام
الله من العدم الى
الوجود
say الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله as the
liken he created him from
dust
him and he
is next fr ان شاء الله
تعالى
مم عيسى عليه
السلام
all اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واعلي كلمتي الحق والدين المبين
اللهم اغفر لنا ارحمنا وتب علينا وسامحنا
واختم يا ربنا بالصالحات اعمالنا واغفر
لهم للجماعه الحاضرين ووالدينا ووالديهم
اجمعين والى من انشا هذا المكان ومن عمل
فيه لله من خير وبر واحسان اللهم من اراد
بالمسلمين سوء فاجعل دائره السوء تدور
عليه اللهم تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا مولا انك انت التواب
الرحيم اللهم انا نسالك حبك وحب من احبك
وحب عمل يقربنا الى حبك اللهم ات انفسنا
تقواها وزكها انت خير من زكاها انت وليها
ومولاها اللهم انا نعوذ بك من علم لا ينفع
ومن قلب لا يخشع ومن عين لا تدمع ومن نفس
لا تشبع ومن دعوه لا يستجاب لها اللهم
علمك بحالنا يغني عن سؤالنا فرج هم
المهمومين ونفس كرب
المكروبين اللهم واشفي مرضى المسلمين
اللهم واحقن دماء المسلمين اللهم احقن
دماء المسلمين في كل مكان والف بين قلوبهم
يا رب العالمين اللهم ارنا واياهم الحق
حقا ووفقنا اتباعه وارنا الباطل باطلا
وفقنا اجتنابه وفقنا للعمل بكتابك سنه
نبيك محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ان الله
يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى
وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم
لعلكم
تذكرون ولذكر الله اكبر واقم الصلاه يرحمك
الله